هي دودة العمل
ndc للقيام بالأنبوب Fire nodera Jens
حافظ على قطعتنا المكونة من 3 قطع Damukua
ربما قبل 71 عامًا شجعت في شيبويا
يُطلق على رامين الغلاف الجوي اسم Toyama الأسود الأصلي
شعاع
صحيح Doon OK ، هناك أرائك صينية ، إلخ.
غالبًا ما لا يقول السكان المحليون Toyama black
اضغط على حقيبة بوب القديمة 9 الديك ريسا
نموذج البريد Seikan Kobayashi
الحالة الرئيسية تطبيق ويب جيد لعبة البوكر 4 لي للاحتياجات r
الاطفال تفعل
في غارة جوية
لا تكن حقلاً محترقًا من حولك
في ذلك الوقت ، لم يكن لدي الكثير لآكله.
مثل طبق جانبي من الأرز
تم إنشاء المؤسس وهو يتساءل عما إذا كان هناك شيء ما
بادئ ذي بدء ، أعتقد أن السبب في ذلك هو أن الريش أسود حقًا.
هذا هو لون الشيء الذي لم يتم إرفاقه Nya 9 Ryotaka
يحتوي على 5 أنواع من طيات صلصة الصويا والطيات السرية.
أعتقد أنه لا يزال أسود
hd 12 سنة Toyama Black Ramen Half Tiger Space Toyama
[موسيقى]
Buberre Tokyo Dairy Paper Master
أعتقد أنه رامين بصري نادر جدًا في ذلك الوقت
بعد كل شيء الانطباع الأول مهم
ما يميز لون توياما الأسود هو أنه يبدو غامقًا.
يبدو مالحًا ، لكنه في الواقع خفيف جدًا
في الأساس كل شيء يخرج
حساء السنة العاشرة ، شار سيو والسلطة هي كل هذا يمكنك القيام به
توياما الأسود هو
إنه ليس الشخص الذي اخترعته.
هذه خطوة واحدة بمعنى أن Toyama Black جعلها مشهورة في اليابان.
انا اتسائل
[موسيقى]